I'm not old were seen as an abyss and
trees as evil forest spirits in the
mythical world the forest was once a
breeding ground for anxiety home to
howling wolves and wicked witches the
Grimm brothers wrote famous children's
tales that played to the fears so
typical of the Middle Ages but the
dueling at the 18th century brought
enlightenment and wiesen that banished
spooks and spirits from the forest and
stripped it of its secret the German
romantics rebelled and turned their
woodlands into soul escapes of personal
reflection
they deemed them as a symbol of German
identity for it was at the Toyota burger
forest that the Germanic tribes defeated
the Romans in the 9th century AD a giant
statue celebrates their leader Hammond
as the founder of the German state then
came the Nazis with their take on German
identity later there was reindeer Kitsch
and in the 1980s panic about the effects
of acid rain on the nation's trees the
woods have played a part in Germany's
ever changing history but in today's
modern world The Woodlands are a place
for walkers day-trippers and those
looking for a little adventure but that
is not to say that the myths aren't
still lurking somewhere between the
trees
you